(bright music)
(Father Nellos speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] On a Greek
peninsula sits Mount Athos,
one of the most important centers
of the Christian Orthodox world.
Isolated and autonomous,
monks first arrived
in the ninth century, and it is a place
where time has stood still.
Access is very limited, and the location
is hard to get to, especially
on the Southern side
where cabins sit on cliffs,
a hundred feet above the sea.
(enchanting string music)
(Father Nellos speaks in foreign language)
(upbeat string music)
A monk's life on Mount Athos
is almost exclusively dedicated to prayer.
Beyond that, life is rooted
in self-sustainability.
Monks grow their own
fruits and vegetables,
make their own wine, and
do any required handy work.
(upbeat string music)
(Father Nellos speaks in foreign language)
(bright guitar music)
Mount Athos remains a holy site
where numbers of visitors
and prospective monks
continues to rise every year.
(bright guitar music)
To some outsiders, the
simple communal life
may seem archaic, but for the monks,
it is a peaceful existence
with no distractions.
(Father Nellos speaks in foreign language)
(bright guitar music)